wir waren dieses Jahr in Italien im
Urlaub da haben sie in der größten Pampa
überall den besten Empfang und dann
fahre ich nach Kühlungsborn oder auf dem
Darß und leg mein Handy weg weil es
nicht benutzen kann bin eigentlich
generell immer nicht erreichbar dann
nervt natürlich ne wer was von mir
möchte der kann mir eine Postkarte
schicken eine Postkarte weil das Netz
nicht für eine Nachricht reicht ein
Festnetzanruf weil das Handy keinen
Empfang hat klingt alles völlig aus der
Zeit gefallen doch in einigen Teilen
Deutschlands sitzen die Leute noch immer
im Funkloch mal eben von unterwegs
arbeiten einen Film Stream oder einfach
nur telefonieren kann man hier vergessen
dabei versprechen Politiker in so
ziemlich aller Parteien seit Jahren
Besserung schnelles Internet und
Mobilfunk überall sind genauso wichtig
wie Strom und Wasser heutzutage es
werden keine Funklöcher in Deutschland
bleiben wir wollen schlichtweg vom
Funkloch zum Highspeed Weltmeister
werden doch vom Highspeed
Weltmeistertitel sind wir noch weiter
entfernt 41% der Deutschen geben an in
den vergangenen 12 Monaten Probleme mit
Ausfällen oder Abbrüchen gehabt zu haben
aber warum ist das so ich bin Lana
grosse und das hier es Kontext insgesamt
liegt Deutschland im internationalen
Vergleich weit hinten zum Beispiel bei
der Internetgeschwindigkeit hier belegt
Deutschland gerade mal Platz 44 sogar
Rumänien und Bosnien-Herzegowina
schneiden besser ab die viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt hat also
richtig lahmes Internet und das obwohl
Deutschland ein durchaus lukrativer
Markt ist 50 Milliarden Euro Umsatz gibt
es hier zu holen mit fast 170 Millionen
Mobilfunkanschlüssen alle nutzen Netze
dieser drei Anbieter Telekom Vodafone
und Telefonica besser bekannt als O2 und
ziemlich viele haben mit diesem ziemlich
nervigen Problem zu kämpfen Daniela
Helms muss kreativ werden um an ihrer
Telefonkonferenz teilzunehmen zu Hause
in godern bei Schwerin hat sie weder
schnelles Internet noch ein stabiles
Mobilfunknetz daher geht's raus auf
einen Hügel in der Nähe des funkmasters
auf dieser Karte ihr wie groß das
Problem mit der Netzabdeckung in
Deutschland ist auf rund 3% der Fläche
gibt es sogenannte weiße Flecken hier
kann man zwar telefonieren aber keine
mobilen Daten nutzen also weder eine
E-Mail verschicken noch eine News App
laden und dann sind dann noch Gegenden
mit sogenannten grauen Flecken hier sind
nur ein oder zwei Anbieter aktiv wer den
Vertrag bei einem anderen abgeschlossen
hat hat einfach Pech gehabt und gar
keinen oder schlechtes Netz was von
grundsätzlich sagen kann ist das bei
allen schlechter wird immer aufs Land
geht es auch kein Wunder da lohnt sich
weniger Basisstationen aufzubauen ist ja
klar Mobilfunkanbieter bauen am ehesten
da aus wo der meiste Umsatz zu erwarten
ist also da wo viele potenzielle Kunden
im Leben im Vergleich dazu ist der
Aufbau von Masken auf dem dünn
besiedelten Land erstmal ein
Verlustgeschäft und auch der Betrieb
nicht wirklich interessant um Funklöcher
zu stopfen hat die Gemeinde bereits 2014
geholfen einen Sendemast zu errichten
allen Mobilfunkanbietern wurde angeboten
hier ihre Technik zu installieren aber
seitdem ist leider bis auf die Polizei
und die Feuerwehr niemand auf den Mast
mit draufgegangen obwohl es für alle zur
Verfügung stehen würde alles also die
Schuld profitorientierter Unternehmen
natürlich nicht sagen die Unternehmen
das hängt zusammen zum Beispiel mit
mangelnden verfügbaren Grundstücken weil
wir keinen finden der uns das vermieten
möchte oder weil Genehmigungsprozesse
für den Aufbau eines Standortes sehr
lang sind ganz unrecht haben sie damit
nicht vor allem beim Thema Bürokratie
wenn Sie ein Funkmast aufbauen wollen
dann dauert das derzeit 18 Monate bis
der Stempel vom Amt auf dem Antrag ist
so dass sie überhaupt anfangen können zu
bauen ich höre natürlich schon zum einen
dass in Deutschland die
Genehmigungsverfahren für
Antennenstandorte die langsamsten sind
ganz Europa Antennen reichen aber nicht
um beispielsweise eine Nachricht zu
verschicken und damit kommen wir zum
nächsten Problem die Knappen
Mobilfunkfrequenzen die braucht es
nämlich um Daten vom Smartphone zum Mast
und schließlich zum Empfänger oder zu
Empfängerin weiterzuleiten was erstmal
total technisch klingt hat ziemlich
große Auswirkungen für Neumarkt es gibt
nämlich nur wenige Frequenzen für
Funkanwendungen und auch Polizei oder
Radiosender sind auf sie angewiesen also
werden Mobilfunklizenzen zentral von der
Bundesnetzagentur verwaltet und an
Netzbetreiber versteigert
milliardenschwere Investitionen nur für
vier bis sechs Lizenzen reichen in
Deutschland die Frequenzen deshalb
werden sie vom Staat versteigert bei der
ersten Versteigerung im Jahr 2000 geht
es UMTS-Frequenzen besser bekannt als 3G
10 Jahre später werden dann die LTE
funklizenzen versteigert und die
Betreiber verpflichten sich bis 2016 90%
der unterversorgten Haushalte mit 4G zu
versorgen und zwar zuerst achtung auf
dem Land
diejenigen die diese Frequenzen
ersteigern haben die Pflicht das Netz
zuerst dort aufzubauen und erst dann in
den Verdichtungsräumen doch auf dem Land
verdienen die Mobilfunk-Unternehmen
nicht ihr Geld
und jetzt wird's interessant nur zwei
Jahre später erfüllen die Unternehmen
bereits alle Auflagen doch warum gibt es
dann immer noch Gegenden ohne Empfang
ganz einfach die Vorgaben der
Bundesnetzagentur waren zu lassen
die haben sich nämlich an Haushalten
orientiert nicht an der Fläche und so
bleiben dünn oder nicht besiedelte
Gebiete weiterhin ohne Empfang
ich sehe tatsächlich hier eher ein
Versäumnis bei der Politik die einfach
bei den Vergaberichtlinien hätte dafür
sorgen müssen dass die Netzbetreiber
strengere Auflagen bekommen eben diese
Netzbetreiber haben übrigens zum Teil
astronomische Summen für die Frequenzen
ausgegeben umgerechnet 50,8 Milliarden
Euro bringt die erste Versteigerung der
UMTS Frequenzen ein und auch bei den
späteren werden Milliarden gezeigt
dieses Geld fehlt danach für den Ausbau
einen Kritikerin viel zu lange habe die
Regierung den Ausbau gebremst in dem sie
mobilfunkanbiete zur Kasse wart 2019
findet die bisher letzte Auktion für den
aktuellen Standard 5g statt einen
Marathon erst nach 497 Runden und 12
Wochen ist die Versteigerung beendet
Telekom Vodafone Telefonica und 1&1
Drillisch bekommen den Zuschlag und die
Auflagen werden verschärft 6,5
Milliarden Euro haben die vier
Telekommunikationsunternehmen bei der
Versteigerung der 5g Lizenzen vor einem
Jahr zahlen müssen bis Ende
22 sollen 98% aller deutschen Haushalte
die hohe Geschwindigkeit nutzen können
doch bis heute sind die Zielvorgaben
teilweise nicht erreicht Konsequenzen
für die Unternehmen bisher so gut wie
keine und auch Kundinnen können
mangelnde Leistungen kaum ahnten
kündigen ist oft keine Option denn es
fehlt an Alternativen auf dem deutschen
Mobilfunkmarkt gibt es wenig Wettbewerb
drei große Anbieter teilen sich den
Markt auf nämlich Telekom Vodafone und
Telefonica in der Hoffnung den
Wettbewerb anzukurbeln kommt 1&1 vor
vier Jahren dazu hängt beim Netzausbau
aber hinterher von 1000 zugesagten neuen
Masken stehen Anfang Mai gerade mal 20
und so ist 1&1 genau wie andere Anbieter
darauf angewiesen die Netze der
Konkurrenz gegen Bezahlung zu nutzen
wenn wir 5,4 Milliarden investieren und
diese Netze aufbauen dann kannst doch
nicht sein dass andere diese Netze dann
mitnutzen oder zu niedrigeren Kosten
einfach einbinden können in ihrer
Infrastruktur fakt ist Telekom VOD und
Telefonica sind nicht dazu verpflichtet
anderen die eigenen Netze zu gleichen
Bedingungen zur Verfügung zu stellen das
ist bei früheren Versteigerungen noch
anders mit der sogenannten Dienste
Anbieter Verpflichtung wird genau das
festgeschrieben und damit mehr
Konkurrenz ermöglicht diese
Verpflichtung gibt es für den
Mobilfunkstandard 5g aber nicht wir
können die Unternehmen die einen
Mobilfunknetz haben nicht dazu
verpflichten dritte auf ihre Netze zu
lassen das sagt der damalige Präsident
der zuständigen Bundesnetzagentur aber
eben diese formal unabhängige Behörde
soll von dem damaligen CSU
Verkehrsminister andreas Scheuer unter
Druck gesetzt worden sein so zu
entscheiden das Ergebnis keine weitere
Dienste Anbieter Verpflichtung und
weniger Wettbewerb ganz im Sinne von
Telekom Vodafone und Telefonica im
Gegenzug sollten die ihre Netze
schneller ausbauen aber eigentlich
sollten die Betreiber diese 500 Löcher
bis Ende des Jahres stopfen laut einem
Bericht der Bundesnetzagentur steht erst
knapp ein Fünftel der Masken kommen wir
zum dritten und letzten erleben lange
gab es keine politische Strategie beim
Thema Netzausbau und mit lange meine ich
wirklich lange man glaubt nicht aber als
ich Bundeskanzlerin wurde gab es das
iPhone noch nicht in all den Jahren
haben politisch Verantwortliche vor
allem auf den Markt gesetzt und
entsprechend schwache Vorgaben gemacht
wir haben eigentlich die Digitalisierung
nie wirklich zu Chefsache gemacht das
war vielen PolitikerInnen irgendwie
wichtig aber dann doch nicht so
wichtiger ist dass man eine richtige
Strategie mal auf den Weg hätte bringen
sollen stattdessen ging durch verteilte
Zuständigkeiten nichts voran auf ein
internetministerium das digitale Themen
bündelt konnte sich schwarz rot nicht
einigen Kompetenz Gerangel um das
Zukunftsthema Internet Stückwerk statt
ein klares Konzept die Internetpolitik
der Bundesregierung bleibt unkonkret
drei Minister fürs digitale das sind
halt einfach zwei zu viel
schließlich wird eigens eine Beauftragte
der Bundesregierung für Digitalisierung
Berufen
CSU-Politikerin Dorothee Bär soll es
richten wir wollen nach wie vor 5g
Leitmarkt werden und wir wollen
natürlich 5g Flächen deckend nur über
das Wie scheint man sich nicht so einig
zu sein wir sind jetzt keine
Mobilfunkanbieter und keine
Infrastruktur Bereitsteller für
Sendemasten doch nur wenig später
passiert eigentlich genau das also die
Bundesregierung will überall dort
Sendemasten aufstellen wo die privaten
Telekommunikationsunternehmen keine
bauen wollen weil es einfach nicht
wirtschaftlich ist für sie wir haben
eine
Mobilfunkgesellschaft gegründet die dort
wo es keinen wirtschaftlicher Anreiz
besteht genau diese Aufgabe auch
vorgenommen vornehmen wird 1,1
Milliarden Euro sollen der 2021
gegründeten Mobilfunk
Infrastrukturgesellschaft dafür zu
Verfügung stehen bisher ist das Geld
jedoch alle mit ihren Aufbau geflossen
im letzten Jahr kostete allein die
Verwaltung 30 Millionen Euro und jetzt
raten Sie mal wie viele Handymasten hat
diese Mobilfunk Infrastruktur aus dem
Hause scheuer gebaut jemanden Idee ja
nein sie hat mehr als 0 gebaut sie hat
einen gebaut doch auch die
Ampelkoalition hält an der Gesellschaft
fest und aus dem Ministerium für Verkehr
und digitale Infrastruktur wird das
Ministerium für digitales und Verkehr
ein neuer Name für eine neue Politik wir
hatten natürlich große Hoffnungen darauf
dass endlich mal eine Bundesregierung
eine richtige Strategie auf dem Weg
bringt stattdessen ist es ein
Sammelsurium schon bereits laufender
Projekte teilweise von der
Vorgängerregierung plus unkonkreten
könnte man mal Vorhaben und trotzdem
deutschland hat in den letzten Jahren
beim Ausbau der Mobilfunknetze durchaus
Fortschritte gemacht die hatten Auflagen
an die Mobilfunkbetreiber sind ein
erster Schritt damit die Zahl der
Funklöcher sinkt
flächendeckende Netze wie in anderen
Ländern bleiben wohl ein Traum in
anderen Ländern hat vor allem eine Sache
zu besseren Netzen geführt nationales
Roaming also die Nutzung der Netze
anderer Betreiber damit Kundinnen immer
vom Besten Netz profitieren das könnte
zumindest zeitweise auch bei uns helfen
wenn die Anbieter dazu bereit werden
eine Enteignung das heißt jemand hat
investiert und eine Behörde sagt du
musst dein Netz jemandem anderen zur
Verfügung stellen in Deutschland sind
wir in der Marktwirtschaft das heißt
Enteignungen gehören sich eigentlich gar
nicht und wie geht es jetzt weiter
eigentlich müssten schon bald neue
frequenzvergaben stattfinden denn Ende
2025 laufen wichtige Mobilfunklizenzen
aus für die Bundesnetzagentur wäre das
die Gelegenheit die Netzbetreiber
stärker in die Pflicht zu nehmen mit
strengeren Vorgaben und Sanktionen
sollten Sie beim Ausbau hinterherhinken
aber ob es so kommen wird
was sind eure Erfahrungen mit dem
Handynetz
schreibt es mir gerne in die Kommentare
und abonniert auch gerne unseren Kanal
wenn euch auch interessiert woher die
Probleme bei der Deutschen Bahn kommen
schaut euch dazu gerne unsere Kontext
Folge an und wenn ihr mehr zu
Digitalisierung in Deutschland wissen
wollt empfehle ich euch diesen Beitrag
von meinen Kollegen